good afternoon welcome I have known a
lot of people in the academic political
and business worlds who have a very
well-established Wednesday morning
ritual each picks his or her copy of the
Financial Times and go straight ahead to
read Martin Wolf's column this habit is
understandable those of us who for
professional reasons are in need of
following the evolution of the economy
and the geopolitics of the world know
well that
reading Martin's articles is a habit
that is practically indispensable it's
indispensable and also very enjoyable
Martin has a unique capacity to describe
analyze and debate complex economic
phenomena and ideas and he does this
with outstanding clarity and lucidity
despite being an economist for us we all
know we economies do a very poor job in
communicating our propositions or ideas
to other professions and to the public
at large fortunately we have Martin and
unfortunately we have only a few others
as proof of the exception to the rule
Martin has been fulfilling this role of
explaining economics to the public at
large and also to our own profession
consistently since he joined the
Financial Times I think 17 years ago and
let me tell you that he has done it
again this year in a masterful way with
the publication of his book on why
globalization works in my opinion
Martin's new book is the most accessible
coherent comprehensive and lucic work
that has been published on this subject
at least until now I am particularly
thankful to Marty not only because his
book deals with a number of the issues
that we pursue at the Center for the
Study of globalization but also because
the publication of his book book came
just in time to be assigned as required
reading for the course that the entries
navasana and myself are now teaching
economics 300 and I am taking careful
note of these students that are
attending the lecture but I will take
more careful note of those that are not
attending the lecture and they will pay
the consequence so it's great to have
such an excellent book available but I
think it's even better to have its
author with us now so please less
welcomed very warmly Martin wolf
oh dear
first of all it's a tremendous honor to
be here in this great university as a
journalist I'm not sure that I would
even claim anymore to be an economist
and I think many economists would doubt
whether I ever was one I like many of
the qualities required to be an
economist one of them is I am capable of
the completely impenetrable prose and
secondly I am incapable of the even more
impenetrable impenetrable algebra so I
had to fall back on journalism instead
and because in the last resort it was
the best I could do with my with such
talents as I heard in an earlier stage
of my life I was a bureaucrat at the
World Bank indeed that's where I met him
and I have to say I was even less suited
for that than I was suited for being a
professional academic economist so I
ended that probably as since I believe
in comparative advantage where I had to
be being in Yale nonetheless is a bit
daunting in particularly in front of
this audience which contains so many
immensely distinguished scholars one of
the reasons I think that very few people
would have dared to write this book is
that it requires inordinate self
confidence or ignorance to attempt to
write a single work which covers such a
vast vast theme as as this one because
what I have tried to do is essentially
treat the economics of globalization in
its broadest possible respect as in all
its in all its many aspects I cannot
therefore obviously in the 25 or 30
minutes I will speak begin to cover all
that is contained in the book and I'm
not going to attempt to do so what I
would like to do is introduce what I
think of as some of the major themes of
the book I'll say a bit a little bit
about how its structured and then the
major themes of the book
and then I hope that will allow us to
get in some questions and answer session
into a question and answer session which
I usually find most enjoyable
informative for me and probably most
amusing for the audience because it's
like it's like pricking a ball so let me
just say first of all what I how the
book is structure what I've tried to do
what I try to do first of all is to lay
out the arguments for globalization as
in terms of the market economy as a
whole to me globalization I'll come to
this in a moment is simply the extension
of the market across frontiers and one
has to start by understanding why any
economists would believe indeed anyone
will believe a market economy is a good
idea and it's pretty clear from the
literature if you read the literature on
globalization which is very vast and not
always very distinguished in its
intellectual qualities that many people
doubt but there's any real and good
reason for having market economies at
all so I wanted to do to lay those
arguments out and also to relate them to
the politics of our societies the
connection between the market economy
and liberal democracy which i think is
close and intimate the second thing I
wish to do was to describe the history
of globalization many people seem to
think that international economic
integration or international integration
more broadly is something that was
invented by Reagan and Thatcher and a
few other lunatics in about 1980 and
nothing like this ever happened before
and I wish to make it clear that things
like this had happened before indeed
it's part of a very very long process I
go back only a few thousand years but
the some people I've since discovered
would say that it all started when the
first human beings left Africa about 70
to 100 thousand years ago so I don't go
back far that far back and I do in
particular discuss at some length what
is sometimes called the first modern
globalization namely the period of 1870
or so to 1914 which came to a rather
disastrous end and I will come to that
in in this talk then I have a very very
long section in which I try as best I
can
to go through pretty well all the
arguments I
find relating to the economics of
globalization and I tried to distinguish
the ones that seem to me to make sense
and some of them do from the ones that
don't and then finally I assess the
likelihood that globalization will last
that this process of liberalization will
last and and if it does last what we can
do about it so that's really what the
book tries to do and I think it's
because it is rather perhaps
inordinately ambitious that he also got
inordinately long when I signed with the
Yale University Press I promised to
deliver a text not more than a hundred
thousand words long what they got was
one hundred and thirty thousand words
and twenty-five to thirty thousand words
of footnotes and references and thank
God I was publishing with an academic
press it's all I can say right so that's
what the book is about now for some
strange reasons that I don't understand
my screen is blank and I'm not at
sufficiently much of a genius to work
out what to do about it
so I'm gonna have to look to to look at
the board what I'd like to cover very
briefly is what just five aspects of
this first markets I said I'm going to
talk a little bit about markets and then
I'm going to talk about States because
there is a very powerful and important
aspect of this book in to me at least in
that I emphasize the relationships
mutually supportive relationship it's
between the two then I'm going to touch
very briefly on the argument and these
are going to be touched upon quite
briefly that in some obvious respects
and I won't go into it in great detail
compared with the if you compare this
the present period with the the the late
19th century early 20th century period
that we're not living in a when what is
striking in many ways is how little
globalization there is or in other words
found little integration there is how
fragmented the world economy is in
fundamental respects then I'm going to
have a rather longer section which looks
at one key aspect one of the most
controversial aspects namely growth
inequality and poverty I think many
people are particularly interested that
and then finally I'd like to look at the
the question of threats to globalization
in particular whether we
are likely to experience another period
similar to that of the first half of the
20th century when the integrated world
economy basically collapsed so though
those are the points that I'd like to
touch upon in this lecture first of all
markets and let me start as I just to
spell out what I think of as
globalization for the purpose of this
book if you study the literature on this
subject which I said is vast a great
deal of it is written by sociologists so
I have nothing against sociologists and
some of my best friends including my
wife is a sociologist so but there's a
vast literature about from sociologists
and a large number of people write about
it for in the point of view of cultural
studies and they emphasize the cultural
implications and the broader societal
implications of the process of
integration but my book is is is about
economics it starts from economics and I
essentially define globalization as a
process of integration of economies
through markets across frontier
frontiers there are in essence if you
think about what drives a globalization
process in that sense there are two
underlying forces the first is
technology essentially the costs of of
transport of communications and the
second is policies of liberalization
namely the liberalized liberalisation of
barriers of them at the border now one
of the obvious features of the not only
of the last two centuries but in fact of
millennia has been the progressive right
reduction in the cost of transports and
communications this is one of the things
that human beings should be rather good
at but the process of reduction of cost
of transport communications accelerated
in the course of the 19th century and of
course through the 20th century but I
make the point at some length and I'm
happy to discuss it further that on some
by by some substantial measures though
we can never be quite sure the process
of technological
transformation as it related to
transporter communications was more
rapid and fundamental in the 19th
century than in the 20th century the
reason I emphasize that is again to try
and emphasize that this is not a really
new phenomenon what do I mean by that
well I mean that the invention of the
steam train the the steamship and the
trance and the cable the international
cable completely revolutionized the
ability to transport goods and to
transport information and really for the
first time made possible something like
an integrated world economy and in very
important ways
it was very highly integrated by the
beginning of the 20th century technology
of course continued throughout the 20th
centuries we had in particular the
invention of civil aviation and the most
fundamental change unquestionably was
the speed with which the the primitive
cable technology of the 20 of the 19th
century turned into telephony and
everything all the way down to the to
the contemporary internet so we moved to
a world which particularly the last 30
40 years the principal change in costs
has been cost of communication cost of
transport interestingly seemed to fall
on very little if at all in the last 20
to 30 years so it's really been the
costs of communication these changes
have been linear and consecutive and
consistent but interestingly as I
remarked in the book the the trade
capital flows and so forth have not
followed the same path at all in fact
after a period of very high integration
with very high trade ratios very high
ratios in terms of capital flows lots of
statistics as you suggest a high level
of capital market integration this all
went into reverse between 1914 and 1945
before the liberalisation process
restarted and the important point about
that at the absolutely crucial point is
that the globalization process is was
and remains a policy choice that is to
say government's made a series of
choices which restarted the
liberalization process and restarted the
integration process
this began in the post-war period
predominantly in the transatlantic world
with some countries in East Asia joining
in and then in the last 20 or 30 years
as most people know an increasing number
of developing countries and former
communist countries also transform their
econ economies and in all these cases
and I think it's extremely important to
emphasize that and that is why I start
off with the discussion of the market
what these countries did was more or
less simultaneously with the
relationships often being complicated
and difficult but they more or less
simultaneously liberalized markets
internally and externally this was a
market revolution more broadly in which
countries like China or India or Russia
or Brazil and those of the list is very
very long all made a number of steps
towards greater steps towards the market
economy at home and and integration
abroad and I argue that while it has
been quite customary for trade for it
international economies to argue that in
some sense the case for the market at
home the case for less affair at home is
rather different from the case for free
trade in practice the processes both in
the late 19th and early 20th century and
more recently have been very similar all
above all essentially contemporaneous
that's what happened in the 1980s and
90s and the globalization process which
created all the protests followed from
that so essentially while there was this
long ongoing transformation of
technological opportunities and
particularly the costs of communication
collapsing in the last 3040 years we had
a huge liberalisation restriction and
then liberalisation wave over the last
150 years and we happen to have lived at
the end or we happen to be now and I
hope don't know whether it's at the end
but in in a period of pretty close to
global liberalisation and of course
there's no particular surprise why that
happened it happened because the planned
economy in would look
alternatives had worked seemed to the
policymakers in the countries concerned
by the late 1970s early 1980s to
approved essentially a dead end and they
all decided to a greater or less extent
at the same time to transform their
policies and globalization followed now
the second theme of the book is the role
of states this is a very this theme runs
through the whole whole book if me and a
lot of it I suppose by now is taken for
granted among economists but I think
it's fair to say that there was a long
lengthy period when people who were
interested in markets tended to the view
that in some sense governance and States
didn't matter very much possibly because
many of them lived in countries like
yours or mine and more or less took it
for granted they took for granted the
existence of a reasonably competent
state with a reasonably competent
judicial system in which the prime
minister or President did not steal
everything that moved and and he and as
it turned out anyone who worked on
development as I did in the 1970s
discovered rather to their surprise in
my case perhaps less so to my Indian
colleagues and other colleagues that
these assumptions were not in fact very
realistic that there were a very large
number of states societies where you
could not assume a supportive state so
the the the book emphasizes that markets
need strong and supportive states in
fact they need something rather special
a market ISA economy which is going to
be a terrible liberal democracy is they
need something rather special and when
you think about it it is so special that
it's rather surprising that it ever
exists and that is you need a state in
fact I'm just writing a column about
this for Wednesday which is very strong
that is to say it had truly has a
monopoly of coercive force that you can
be reasonably confident when you go out
to about your business the only that the
only institution likely to take all your
money away for
you is in fact the police force and the
courts are not your neighbor or
neighbors but at the same time you have
to be confident that this very powerful
stage is constrained that it will say it
will be law governed and act in
accordance with the rules and principles
of its own legal and constitutional
order and as I point out this is not to
put it mildly a novel thought since it's
been had by many far greater people
including particularly Thomas Hobbes
it's not quite obvious why such a state
should ever exist why should there ever
have emerged states which I think will
have the capacity to take everything
that moves and yet or is not in even
doesn't move and yet forebears to do so
and the the answer I give at some length
is that there it seems to be have been
in a number of societies but I think
quite particularly in in the West in the
in the in the last two three hundred
years and of course in a number of
Western offshoots like the United States
the emergence of such a state as a
result of a range of factors coming
together among them the competition
among states for resources they weren't
they weren't truly monopolies because
people could leave and resources could
leave if they if they started governing
badly enough constitutional reforms
which really did shift power towards
assemblies and quite profound
institutional reforms the creation of
genuinely independent and genuinely
honest bureaucratic Elise if this is
pretty well a universal process which
has achieved these things in the in a
number of Western states unfortunately
as we've discovered in the last 40 50
years such states are rare far more
common are predatory states or weak
states those that lack in fact an
effective monopoly of force I think it's
not very difficult to think of countries
to the south of the United States which
which essentially the government lacks a
monopoly of force think of Columbia for
example and of course there are now a
very large number of failing states
which are which are essentially
dysfunctional way where you have
something close to anarchy
as I've argued good state seem to be
created by a complicated historical
process and I've listed some of the
factors and but the the main point I
make is if you wanted to understand why
it is that there has been such an
extraordinary divergence in wealth
across the world I argue that the most
important single cause is and of course
it's a vicious circle I'm not suggesting
this is where it all start is a sort of
Terror dreadful spiral into which the
whole range of countries have fallen in
which very bad states lead to
essentially the the collapse of basic
state services and the ability to jet
raise revenue this persuades this
obviously means that people have to look
after themselves and the last thing they
will ever do is is provide taxes to the
state so the state gets even worse and
you have you basically end up in
something like a Hobbesian universe and
it seems to me that that is a
description alas of fairly large
proportions of today's world and above
all that part of the today's world in
which globalization is definitively not
working I end the book by arguing that
this is our greatest challenge and I end
it very carefully if I may saying it's
our greatest challenge because I don't
know what the solution is but it does
seem to me that's the problem and say
well that's the second big theme the
third being theme of the book is that if
you look at what has happened as has
happened into our world economy and this
here we can have some interesting
debates about how far you think
globalization could go and if you
compare where we are today
with the late 19th and early 20th
century I think it's it's pretty clear
that in trade and particularly in
productive systems our economy is more
integrated than the economy has ever
been before this is partly because
trade liberalization has in fact gone
further than ever before across the
world as a whole in the late 1930 20th
century Britain practiced free trade but
it was the only major country to do so
while tariffs are close to zero in many
developed countries today they're really
very very low but in addition modern
Communications has facilitated the
integration of production process across
frontier in a way that was quite
inconceivable 100 years ago but as I
note the integration of labor markets
and labor migration is definitively
smaller today and it continues to be
despite the pressures for migration much
smaller than it was in the late 19th and
early 20th centuries probably three or
four times smaller if you take the
proportion of the population of the
world that is now living in countries
different from those in which he was
born
and if you take as Dani Rodrik points
out he as an indication of labor market
distortions or segmentation the
differences in wages across the world
sort of seventy to one or so in real
terms it's pretty clear that the labor
market is spectacularly segmented but
interestingly the same seems to be true
of capital markets I give a whole host
of statistics and I can go through this
which suggests that in terms of net
capital flows from rich countries to
poor countries in fact in terms of
capital market capital market
integration the famous Feldstein Carioca
sort of puzzle that self-sufficiency of
economies in capital and so forth we
have probably a less integrated world
than we did in the late 19th and early
20th century and we certainly have one
which is less good at transferring
capital from richer countries to poor
countries as I'm sure you all know
because I think it is the single most
important fact about today's world
economy but incomparably the largest
recipient of capital in the world is the
country in which you're living and the
developing countries as a whole are in
aggregate very strikingly net capital
exporters so this I think supports the
proposition that in some rather
important respects the world economy
doesn't work as well as you would have
thought as it did
a hundred years ago I think there are a
whole host of reasons for that which I'm
happy to discuss partly to do with the
monetary regime the move from the gold
standard to floating partly to do with
the uncertainty of property rights in
many developing countries but in essence
we have only a very partial
reintegration then I'm going to discuss
if my fourth big theme which is really
taking out one chapter but I think it's
in many ways the most interesting for
economists on of this book on looking at
some of what has happened in this
globalization error the last 25 years on
growth and distribution across the world
poverty and so forth and I think there's
no great secret about this in essence
the era of globalization sometimes
people call some people sometimes people
call globalization equals
Americanization I think a more
interesting way of thinking about it is
the globalization equals Asia Minor
Asian ization in essence what is
happening in this period partly because
of the globalization process but more
profoundly because of narrowly defined I
think more profoundly because the number
of Asian countries above all the Giants
have begun to sort out their own
domestic policy systems in a sensible
direction has been a staggering reversal
simply staggering reversal of a very
fairly long-standing historical pattern
that began in the early 19th century and
really continued to the middle of the
20th which was basically who had this
huge economic revolution in the world
and Asia which contains well over half
of humanity and has historically clearly
been the most advanced region in terms
of economic activity stagnated
completely and that started to change in
the 50s and 60s with Japan above all and
then what's the Chinese sometimes I
think called the four little dragons
Korea Taiwan Hong Kong and Singapore but
of course in the last 25 years China and
India have joined this party and now we
are talking about half of humanity and
that is the big story of what's happened
and this story is shown I think somewhat
in this in this chart just to sort of
give you some indication of of some of
the what's been going on in the last 200
years and what may have been going on in
the last 10 20 years this is from a
paper by bourguignon Morrison's quite a
well-known paper in which they did
something I have to admit very heroic
but still very exciting which is to try
and make estimates like all these
economic history things brave estimates
of what's happened to the global
inequality among households if you
aggregate the whole world in two sets of
households over the last 200 odd years
and the method they've chosen they used
the mean logarithmic deviation and
everybody here knows what that means
probably more than I do and the the
essentially they've been advantage of
this particular measure is that it
allows you to decompose the growing
inequality in the world or the changes
in inequality among households into two
causes because it they're additive one
is inequality between country groups
which is the sort of bright purple line
and the other is which is the inequality
between the means of the distribution in
each country the average for each
country
and the other is the inequality within
country groups which is the darker
purple line in the in green is the total
and what you see and I think it's the
most important point to understand about
the world economy and also about how
globalization might affect inequality in
this way is that from the period of 1820
to about 1880 or so on their figures
1980 or so on their figures there was a
huge increase in inter household
inequality and that was driven entirely
entirely by differences in average
incomes among countries or to more
precisely in the differences of rates of
growth of countries what happened in
therefore in the 19th and first 2/3 of
the 20th century was that countries some
countries did very well grew
consistently particularly Europe America
Japan and others didn't and the result
was this growing inequality among
countries over this period in fact there
was a sharp decline in inequality within
countries or modest decline in the early
20th century which has since been
reversed modestly but if in the last 20
years what the their data suggests and I
think I suggest and I will show you one
other source
it seems to me consistent with the other
evidence is that in the last 20 years or
so this is this has gone into reverse
and it's gone into reverse for a very
very simple and obvious reason which is
that China and again to a lesser extent
India which contained 40% of the world's
population are very close to it have
started growing consistently faster in
terms of GDP per head than the world
mean and because they've been doing that
their relative income on average has
risen and that has dragged that their
households with it and therefore in the
global census started to reverse
inequality so the this just reinforces
something that I've always believed that
the most important single determinant of
global inequality is and remains the
relative growth of nations and here I
take a chart from Sala Amato who's using
exactly the same measure but much more
detailed data sources it's exactly the
same measure and it shows global
inequality in exactly the same way from
1970 to the late 1980s and you see a
quite marked decline which seems to
support the hypothesis that there was
the reversal interestingly you will see
the reversal reversed itself in the
early 90s that's quite important because
there was a World Bank analyst who who
argued that what happened in the early
90s showed that in fact the world's
inequality was getting worse and the
reason for that is quite interesting
it's basically Tiananmen Square the
collapsing Chinese growth following that
reversed the whole pattern China in
other words has been dominating this
picture to an extraordinary degree now I
look very briefly at what's been
happening to the extreme poverty as
measured and there's a huge controversy
about whether there's a sensible measure
and I'm not going to go into all that
because I simply don't at the time and
taking too long anyway that if you take
the standard World Bank's measure of
poverty which is one dollar a day at PPP
and nine
in 85 prices they wobble about the year
but Atlas is a 1985 prices and again
using essentially the same data as
bourguignon and Morrison this shows the
very long run pattern for both absolute
numbers and proportions of the world
population who were as it were
desperately poor on the margin of
subsistence and the interesting thing
about these data I think showed two
things three things first that the
proportion of the world's population in
this situation has declined
progressively since industrialization
began from close to 90 percent down to
20 percent and that is essentially what
industrialization is achieved it has
removed us from living in a world in
which almost everybody's on the margin
of destitution and starvation - one in
which a relatively small proportion of
the population is and that has been
continuing progressively and it
continued rapidly in the age of
globalization so you can see secondly
the absolute numbers rose until probably
1980 or so when they started to fall and
they rose because in essence the growth
of the world's population is offset the
proportion of decline over the period
since 1918 20 that the world's
population has increased six-fold and of
course the world's population in the
last 40 50 years has tended to rise
fastest in the poorest countries it's
maybe more difficult to achieve a
decline but anyway this is what's
happened to global poverty and if you
look at the last 20 years and here there
are three different measures I'm using
measures computed computed by three
different sources the World Bank sorted
by land Sally Martin they all come out
with the conclusion that the absolute
number of people not just the proportion
in the absolute poverty extreme
destitution had fallen in the last
period of globalization this is the
1990s again consistent with what it
seems to have happened to growth and
this is the very latest World Bank data
which are I think quite stunning
at least they're from a consistent
source and the figures of what's
happened in Asia are absolutely
staggering
they take the same criteria except that
it's actually 92 prices I don't know
what that means I'm sorry that
disappeared from the chart but
essentially they show that in 1981 the
poor
the number of people in this situation
East Asia and Pacific was 767 million
and by 2001 it had fallen to 284 million
in China went down from and from 606 to
212 there was a much slower decline in
South Asia but a big decline in the
proportion of the population and
everywhere else did bad badly
essentially the era of globalization has
been the era of the Asian miracle or at
least the Asian transformation and if
you look at the proportions of people in
populations and extreme poverty what has
happened in the East Asia and Pacific
region which may I remind you contains
more than 30 percent of the entire
population of the world so seven times
as much as the US the proportions that
have changed there is the largest
proportionate reduction in pop in
poverty in any significant region of the
world in a short period there has ever
been and the World Bank is notorious for
being very conservative in its estimates
of these some think this is because the
world beat back you know there's a
famous joke that the World Bank has a
motto if you've ever been to the world
bases our dream is a world without
poverty and some of us say they're
nightmare is a world without poverty so
given that these are very positive
numbers and they'd support and these are
much more positive in terms of what they
think happened in the in the 80s and 90s
than anything that they showed before
these are quite remarkable changes than
they show in fact of what has happened
in East Asia and even South Asia the
decline many people by the way experts
en will comment on this perhaps many
experts think that the World Bank's
numbers on South Asia are a complete
nonsense and much too pessimistic but
even there they show a very very big
proportion of decline and what is
driving all this these are data are
taken from Angus men's Madison as I said
is essentially that this this period of
73 to 98 has been the period when Asia
rapidly growing Asia with a very high
trade integration very rapid growth of
trade has had an absolutely stunning
report performance over the whole period
GDP per head in Asia excluding Japan
grew at three and a half percent a year
on average and this is three times
almost three times
the world average China of course is
considerably faster than that there is
no place other place in the world that
has done as well and since Asia was
desperately poor to start off with this
is why this process has been equalizing
what is all this got to do with trade
just to conclude this section well I've
just taken some data from the World Bank
study of globalization grades and
poverty I don't want to discuss how far
trade liberalisation per se has been
because it seems to me that's simply
part of the movement towards the market
but one thing is clearly true there's no
question about it that the countries
that did best they here about three
billion people living in these global
interesting countries are countries
which had exceptionally rapid
liberalisation of trade and above all
exceptionally rapid growth of trade so
the one conclusion at least one can
reach I think with some confidence is
that integration into trade into the
world globalization has been consistent
with exceptionally rapid trade
performance growth performance and
exceptionally rapid reductions in
poverty as I have indicated you so that
is I think the good side of the big
picture there are many many other points
in the book but that will do enough that
will at least raise some questions I
hope and lays down some facts about what
has happened in what I generally a very
positive period I won't be able to go
through what went wrong in Africa and
Latin America but I think it will be
clear from what I've said earlier that I
think a lot of it is to do with the way
the state systems have continued to
operate against the interests of the
economy in those regions now the final
thing I want to do and I apologize for
having gone on a bit is to ask the
question well will it all last or are we
again at the end of a period of rapid
integration if you read the what people
wrote in about 1900 it's pretty clear
that nobody imagined that the
catastrophe that was about to befall
them would in fact befall them and that
the whole integrating system was going
to fall to pieces in a relatively short
period I add you in the book that there
were essentially four forces coming
together that
undermined and destroyed the Liberal
system at that time global geostrategic
and security and conflict first and
foremost the the wars second
macroeconomic instability above all the
breakdown of the world monetary system
of the Great Depression then the way
protectionist interests work the the
room for protectionist logrolling
particularly the US which was then
matched by other countries and finally
essentially in the very broadest sense
dirige East ideas and I'll go very
briefly through what I think about the
plausibility of these as threats today
first on insecurity as we know the first
part of the 20th century was the era of
the world wars there were huge conflicts
among the great powers they tore to
pieces the European economic system and
Europe was then the dominant part of the
world economy now today of course we
have fear of terrorism and that clearly
is potentially a real obstacle to
Commerce it's certainly obstacle to
movement of people and it's potentially
an obstacle to the movement of goods if
people are concerned that bombs nuclear
and other devices might be put into
containers for example but at least for
the moment the good side of where we
eyes the great powers are at least
roughly on the same side and nobody
really believes the territorial control
I'll come to this in a moment is the way
towards maintaining power risks ahead
well I just like to mention three the
rise of China we are witnessing one of
the great transformations in relative
power in world history China is going to
be in my view a superpower and we know
what happened with the rise of Germany
in Japan threatening the stability of
the world system there's obviously a
risk as I said of mega Terrorism Act
which really forced countries to close
borders and I'm going to come in a
moment to the possibility of resource
Wars
I'm modestly optimistic but there are
some real dangers here I think one of
the most interesting specific questions
since I mentioned resource words is the
oil industry since it's the most
important single resource oil and gas
in the world and what is now absolutely
clear for the first time that Asian
industrialization is hugely outstripping
US growth indeed the growth of anywhere
else in the world in terms of its
incremental effects on world demand
China is now a much bigger factor at the
margin in world markets for oil than the
United States if we look here for
example at the incremental in demand for
oil in terms of millions of barrels a
day between 2000 to 2004 you see that
China's growth that is the incremental
increase growth in demand is
significantly greater than that of the
North America as a whole and that all of
Asia are accounted for half of this so
Asia is now the dominant factor in world
markets and there's no doubt in my view
that that's why the real oil price which
is the deep the lighter purple figure
has got to one-up now very high prices
they are as high now as they have been
at any period in the last 30 years
except at the time of the second oil
shock so this is these are now very high
oil prices and the interesting question
obviously is if this continues on up is
there a point at which and you can
answer this the US will say to itself
well we won't want cheap oil we have the
armies that protect all these oil
regions and we want this oil for
ourselves never mind this nonsense about
allowing the Chinese to have it at the
same price as we do have it and if the
US made this possibly quite real
reasonable and realistic view of it's
right to extract oil extract the rent
for itself there will be some quite
interesting conflicts to come the second
one is instability macro instability the
the biggest single catastrophe
undoubtedly was the Great Depression
that led directly to Hitler we all we
all know that and now here the
interesting thing to me and I since
we've had a lot of articles about in the
paper recently is we know about
financial crisis and emerging market
economies that's not a big issue but
what are the risks ahead in the position
of the u.s. current account it's
cumulative net liability position and
its asset price vulnerability
my assumption is that we're all going to
get through this very smoothly because
the world is a wonderfully comfortable
and cozy place but it does seem to me
that there are huge adjustments ahead
and it'll be quite interesting to see
how badly we mishandled them because we
usually do interests here I think
there's really been a very important
positive change at least for those of us
who want to keep the world economy open
really production was dominated by
national companies with the same
interest as their workforce there was no
international system to protect - to
keep the cradle of policy liberal like
the WTO multinational companies changed
the calculus of interest groups in in
protection very radically and in
particularly they create a direct big
conflicts with the interests of their
national workforces and I think that has
serious very very considerably diffused
protectionist pressures not only in
developed countries but essentially
everywhere however we look ahead there's
clearly going to be middle-class anxiety
we can already reek of this in the
United States as services are becoming
much more internationally tradable than
ever before so there's another risk and
finally ideas in the early 20th century
we had belief in socialism a planning
and import substitution today of course
we've got the collapse of socialism the
move towards the market but we do have a
very significant group of
anti-globalization protesters and a very
powerful environmental movement which
basic would like to stop as great as
much as possible so again the question
is are we going to lose faith in the
market and propose going back to much
more restrictive delicious policies
which would again I tend to think also
affect openness to trade what I just
like to close on these thoughts I hope I
at least raise some issues I'm sorry I
don't for a longer than I hope what's my
conclusion I think on the whole despite
all the problems and I discuss the
problems in the book this is a process
that has been largely benign it has
facilitated at least this staggering
Asian transformation which is the region
which contain
most of the world's poor and above all
most of the world's people it is
nonetheless we know very well the
politically fragile project it has
collapsed before it seems to me
conceivable that it could collapse again
and I in the book with the hope that we
can we will build on what we have
achieved spread the opportunities more
widely and not throw the whole effort of
the post-war period to reconstruct a
liberal international system away thank
you very much
this is a question to which I've devoted
a lot of columns you all available on
the air but I don't discuss it in the
book probably because I'm not convinced
the the possible ramifications are I
suppose miss something Barca to give
free emigrate vibration the the number
of European countries Japan and a number
of other Asian countries are I'm on the
verge on of already sooo good experience
absolute population declines and they
are already experiencing much of
southern Europe and Japan absolute labor
force declines and of course very
considerable increases now in the
overall dependency ratio because the old
age dependency ratio is rising faster
than the child dependency ratios
probably in this situation you would
expect countries to be interested in
England vibration as a part of solution
ticking but there is something
non-tradables betrayal is you don't need
the this is creating essential you know
very severe political tension in a quite
large number of countries the Japanese
elite effect decided
the Italians murder party like anything
but anyway the politics of migration is
one huge issue associated potentially
associated with the aging process the
second potential issue is what you might
call the politics or geopolitics of
capital fires one rational but there's
been lots of literature on the
proposition that if you're going through
this process the sensible thing to do
while during the high savings process
heist if you've got the city situation
that sensible thing to do right here in
the statement of student got a savings
and is to invest a lot of money abroad
where people have lots of
invest you regard the European and it's
not happening because in essence the
significant I mean on the scale of
acting make a real difference between
town because I think the developing
world is a whole of China is exception
then it's part role has not persuaded
the developed countries that their
savings are safe in their markets I
treat savers have the belief they invest
money in these countries and then
aspirate back to sell the capital or
least being count twenty thirty years
from now they're going to be
expropriated I think that's the only way
you can see what's going on these
monkeys but that's potentially are very
very important so I think capital and
labor migration are both due related
localization other aspects of aging
which you don't have white important
effects on our societies they don't seem
to me have directly to do with with the
most importantly is that a number of
developed countries are on the basis of
their present commitments to their
workforces in the future to their
population in the future bust and there
is going to be a long-running fiscal
crisis which will be interesting to see
resolved where as I pointed out in one
column of my well over half the
electorate
you look at China and other countries so
are we just everyone's there because
they need to be there interesting
question and what's going to be I think
that the one possible way of seeing the
differences is that it seems to be
plausible lots of reasons believe the
quality of institutions as it were in
each respect has to evolve with the
level of welfare productivity and
efficiency and I think you could thin
you have to remember about China even
compared to Latin America it's a very
very poor country so the the the
opportunities they were exploiting in
the last twenty five years where I think
really quite simple was they didn't
require the most important one as they
related to globalization and indeed for
their development work exploitation or
cheap labor in the in relatively labor
intensive activities which operate in
particular private sectors always as a
template it's very striking that half of
China's exports are generated by clothes
which run by FDI now the the the Chinese
have succeeded in persuading foreign
investors that whatever is going on in
China as a whole the these enclaves will
be treated as if as
right they're not gonna cease at all and
the and that the they will be given a
supportive supportive treatment in terms
of the long-term stability of these
investments so they seem to me to
created a credible quasi property rights
regime for these investors my own guess
is that as China develops and becomes
more sophisticated economy has to
develop with a more sophisticated they
will have to move quite a long way from
where they are for sustained growth at
anything like the present levels and I
think the same applies though in some
ways it has an easier position to get
there to a place like India if you're in
the middle richer then going further on
the involved equated really
substantially more sophisticated
activity and this year were moving those
directions it seems to me that the
quality of the institutions and so forth
mattered war and war what are the
interesting indications of this point
that even countries like which have done
very very well institutions like South
Korea have begun to run up against quite
significant limits in maintaining their
growth momentum even though in terms of
GDP per head
pppt separators by OECD standards are a
pretty poor country so the
transformation that is required towards
the most sophisticated institutions is
really quite quite deep but that is
anyways my view what happened in China
they exploited through liberalisation
through the creation as if you
before FDI a series of very favorable
opportunities which their creditors are
by part working very very cheap labor
elaborate exploit and I think they they
continue for a fourth I think it's
wonderful I think is what the Chinese
government thinks this square process
will run down that is that is my
perception if that turns out with
institutions there are two arguments
here one is that argument that is to say
the movement of capital and traded
substitutes which theory suggests but
there's a which is in fact the right
regarding blanks the argument is in
essence if the market were integrated we
wouldn't get seventy one to one ratio
but if you look at the data on the
difference in the real wages PPP
University of people doing essentially
stimulus passed with similar skills
today you will find the ratio he's very
very much greater that it would it be
this is not surprising because you need
a head to devoted over that period and
average wages tend to go more or less in
line with GDP per head but if you had a
fully integrated labor market those
those differences will of course be
arbitrage the way through movement he'd
suggest one the trade and capital flows
not be enabled offset or even began to
be an adequate offset for at least very
limited weather it is more limited than
it was but I think those will battle the
argument if you if you take price
discrepancies being posted tariffs as it
were or between labor in different
countries say between year in the United
States doing essentially the same thing
driving buses you couldn't you have an
improvement this in this market is
comparison by comparison with a
theoretical world they wish they were no
obstacles to do that the people
my pet will be 20 years from now we'll
be able participate research it will not
be what you are I will consider it
but only for customers safe you can dig
my bones throw stones I think
until three years ago five them twenty
years ago well so that was always very
simple it was to have won the but I
don't think we have the choice so if we
are moving towards the world with more
than one superpower then we have to
manage that well the reason I called it
a threat to stability was that it seems
to me pretty obvious that a world with
two superpowers is less stable in the
world with world superpower and there is
therefore some possibility of least
needs to be possible there's some
possibility of serious conflict between
them now as I said that was how I
believed the world was 2 or 3 years ago
now I'm not so sure
in fact that one superpower is stable
for reasons that must be completely
obvious so happened to say merely I'm
gonna say I did what I did to say is
maybe that Rabbids among great powers
whose relative power are changing and
had pattern in history as John
Mearsheimer point out but always leading
to war and the
so this is going to be really stock will
be the conflict for it out or the only
issue is whether we can contain them
without blowing system apart and if
that's the case then the right of Trevor
is near the creek the move to do I
believe integrate some real problems if
it were a stable do I believe that's
another matter but this is not a stable
I believe because one element in the
rising and that means creative action
attractive not the this is an
interesting question because the
reference point would be the forms of
the US economy in aggregate over the
last 25 years has gone in to quite
puzzling stages as you know between
seventy three hundred nineteen nineties
productivity growth in this country was
surprisingly low surprising since I
thinking economist never adequately
explain why that happened and aggregate
in job market performance was
exceptional we know that but there's a
lot of controversy and I won't have to
distribution of income of that period in
the ninety five period to today
productivity growth has been
extraordinary if I intended apparently
accelerating you had a [ __ ] cycle we
all know that leaks
thank you sir today but as opposed to
most Outsiders including the most
Outsiders in Europe the aggregate
economic performance of the United
States
be regarded is pretty successful and
improving over time the there all the
economic problems I would thought with
roulette will be steamed as relating
more to internal distribution that's an
area of concern to Americans that's an
American problem as it were and the and
possibly some people would raise issues
about sustainability the present
situation but I think most people would
if it had been closed the whole assembly
first question is simple we talked about
in this discussion and maybe we
shouldn't have done this we had a lot of
discussion about whether we should but
for the last two elections we had a lot
of mentors Senator Kerry I have to say
from a point of view of the foreign
newspaper which sells more than 30
copies in the United States in this case
to do I think it's very very difficult
to exactly rate multi write the center
person who's traditionally been rather
favorite Republican presidents even
though what should we do you should do
to to to lower world poverty well I
think that making sure making sure that
the American economy grows and is open
to the world the most egregious
projection is eliminated and you know
eight stories about that have Iraq
I would like to be
well investors would be very generous
the progress is paid from the page of
the stones of bankruptcy and in this
case you're right there's obviously an
enormous investment went into
infrastructure and returns presently
very low but it will be a permanent
benefit as you but more important than
this is and it's very visible if you go
around the world new communication
technologies well including something I
really revolutionized in communications
the largest member of so probably the
monthly errands now and India is also
exploding I when I first went to India
in the 70s
it took about eight or nine hours to get
a line out of the country back to to
Washington didn't try and now here's
part of the world that's why it has an
IT sector and you're worrying about
offshoring so the I regard the
development of telecommunications as
make facilitating not only the
internationalization of the IT industry
the service sector which goes with it
and that's a whole range it is your
financial insurance and so forth it's
also what makes possible the integration
of production across the world that's
how we could operate factories
essentially by the integration of
components and parts ship all over the
world completely possible without it and
quite apart from that I think
communications in either he does allow
individuals
and coming back the TNS question I do
think it's going to prove seriously hard
for the Chinese government for all these
efforts to have to retain the sort of
monopoly over other information that he
used to read wrong is still try to enjoy
without and he doesn't have a lot of
information its ability to control the
bleeding
so I regard the revolution that as we
like the information and technology in
telecommunications revolution and but
not really just economics it's a very
very profound social transformation and
I think by and large the part of the
chair as it were that you see on
television by my party the jack
first of all new special property first
all about globalization there is a huge
debate going on essentially you know
within this country particularly about
the appropriate design of internet
equality regimes and the way they work
we didn't we didn't as it were a
theoretical practical context definitely
in the US
okay and many people believe one that
present intellectual property regime
specifically they relate to copyright
extremely and secondly there was written
in a very particular way in trying to
maintain not innovation which is really
interesting but the Registry's very so a
lot of people Lawrence Lessig is
obviously would argue that these
property right machines are hugely
effective in accepting the obvious point
that there is always in any property
right machine a trade-off between the
cost of a lot of the your grantee and
in the case of pendants law there's also
a lot of questions about the I was going
through all this but I think it's
extremely important to understand that
property rankings are extremely
controversial
there are obviously much more
controversial when you take that given
regime and start translating
internationally because it's a rent
extraction device and in essence it's a
way of transferring very large incomes
from poor countries which are the users
of the intellectual property to the
returners of the international property
when in fact there's actually not the
slightest reason to suppose for a moment
that the willingness of the owners in
special property to innovate will be
seriously affected by their rent
extraction this meant has many many of
us feel that the production of the
intellectual property right machine into
the gap WTO gap their value was wrong
and tricks and and that the
controversies that created were
reasonable and it's a great pity I did
one of those people so I am very worried
about I don't have gone into all the
other things like gene patenting and
some of the trivial and absurd things
that have been granted these are all
very things cases I just got through the
paper there are real worries about the
way property rights issues are working
anyway and there we the worries and
multi Bible you start applying them to
developing countries
if I were and any no specialist in my
book
it is the area in which the attack on
corporate greed is most justified it's
not sustainable
I think is caused more by the rest of
the world that the u.s. is offering
position but I think the dog will how
will it change well at some point in all
the dozens will look at the cost be very
Swift and some markets and really change
record appreciate would have done some
detention by foreign governments which
purchased about a trillion dollars worth
for exchange reserve in 2001 and 2002 at
the dollar falls the trade attack will
begin the that happens it will be
necessary to adjust monetary and fiscal
policy in this country to release the
results
instead of arts and that's actually a
very big check out resources so these
estimates will be our savings rates in
the US dollars will have to rise
Ida public or private presumably both
the great credit binge will come to an
end that will have some interesting
effects the resources the transfers
involved a very large but he's it's
actually quite interesting in the u.s.
is importing now something like a six
the gross savings of the rest of the
world we are really serious terrible
place the adjustments involved will be
very large
my own view has be this made me that if
you extrapolate this process and you
have got a linear trend for the last ten
years the numbers the world becomes so
large ten years from now he just mistake
so I intended to happen sooner rather
than later and he was very unfortunate
the u.s. sat quietly by while these huge
interventions were made but they aren't
the simple answer is I take the head
side view of this what God passed won't
and any any implausible extrapolation of
what's going on I'm getting through that
the whole bendix of diversifying how
these will fit gives you a current
account deficit is something the name
and
gain traction when people are frightened
of Israel at the moment since
essentially bad ideas again for actually
the United States a mini-city
my own view would be if things went
seriously wrong and I don't stuff in the
book what I would imagine is the time in
which the economy works really badly
perhaps because of the scale of the
adjustments that we've just talked about
and the bankruptcies that would be
associated with that
imagine a process like that and a
convergence of the left and the right
view that the solution to this problem
is pressure self-sufficiency a less
reliance on the on the world the
terrorist threats could multiply that
word asbestos on threats that come
through trade and so I'm Lee magically
complements a very bad performance very
real concern about terrorism sociated
the Train the nuclear device that goes
on through the container a major port
and the and the convergence of the left
and right view that what we need to do
is is to to go towards a more
self-sufficient or protective economy I
get oodles of emails from people they're
arguing that the offshoring phenomenon
is is really the ultimate destruction of
the American Dream and that they're
portrayed must be stopped
I attended the view now that the protest
movement would be a relatively small
element in that and he's actually going
far more likely to be driven as
historically we do
United States protections from the right
and to the left and I think in that
respect by the focus on the the first
movement in this context was from
society one of the reasons why I wanted
to make the focus however as it seems to
me and I feel in retrospect that I
didn't make that clear analogy the
sentences that the protest movement
contains a lot of people who ought to
believe in some of the benefits of all
this and that they should see it seems
to be reasonable for the position for
them to take would it be something like
we could do much better than we have
there are clearly real problems with
this globalization stuff but we also
have to recognize some good things
because they would there seem to be a
point in which essentially the left was
turning against trade completely there
and because that was happening at the
same time the right is always open to
nationalist
economic nationalist arguments but I was
concerned if what you have is
essentially convergence between the two
and that still seems to me the most
plausible scenario that's something else
but it seems to me that if I would and
the Europe - it's the same problem
taxation bureau what is striking is that
these three right in the screen left
basically exactly the same things and
that would be I think it would only
become serious if the economy started
performing really really badly as it
didn't need to walk Aaron above all the
legal of course in the thirties the
everything to my book
it was Keynes great view that economics
is not really the important human needs
have far better things to do with their
lives to worry about it but if things go
wrong they sure go wrong